[Music]
there is an intense scene where you get
a pepper spray and I read that you
actually did that on set that room yeah
how come you're like you're scared I'm
scared I'm scared I'm not good enough
you know so it's like it's like when you
go bowling you put up the bumpers you
know you might be able to hit a strike
without the bumpers but why not put the
bumpers up so the guy who did it to me
he's got named Nick Jones jr. who who's
that like my heart he's the Marine who I
went through this whole thing with you
know he knew how to do it in a safe way
so it just seemed like an easier thing
than to have to conjure you how many
times did you do it we just did it twice
real quick it was like just really fast
it wasn't really that crazy quick pepper
spray in the face no big deal yeah every
Marine does it he's a trooper like he
just went for a but yeah I'm sure it's
soccer news remember to be worse than it
was but he's a tough dude like everyone
he knows dudes these days Shia LaBeouf
has lots to celebrate he tied the knot
with actress Mia goth last month and his
road trip film American honey recently
tied for most nominations at the
upcoming Independent Spirit Awards crazy
where was somewhere that you didn't
expect to have a great time that you
really just did Billy Billy yeah of
course I turned 30 at the cheese steak
like corner both of them yeah I went
there and yeah we just hung out there
for my birthday I went there and they
gave me a free sandwich and I was like
cool can I get some fries over like hell
nah man you have to pay for the fries
you know and that's very Philly
[Music]
you